ladies and gentlemen the inflation
numbers have come in and we have the
highest inflation that we have had in
the united states of america in 39 years
this morning the cpi numbers were put
out
6.8
inflation this is what you expect in a
country that is failing where our
currency is failing you expect this in
the developing world you don't expect it
in the strongest economy in the world
the united states of america is under
attack it's under attack from an
internal threat which is inflation as
you can see here going all the way back
to the 1960s
we
have a problem 6.8 inflation is absurd
and when you start to unpack this the
first thing you have to remember is
starting all the way back to last year
when the public health crisis created a
liquidity crisis and investors started
to sell their assets the government and
central bank stepped in and they created
monetary and fiscal policy that was
supposed to inject liquidity in the
market they told you
do not worry about inflation we aren't
worried about inflation as we went
towards the end of the year and into q1
i said you know what
maybe inflation will come
it'll be slightly higher than two
percent
and it's gonna be transitory don't worry
about it not a problem and then by the
summer time when we had five plus
percent inflation they were telling you
don't worry inflation's good for you
well most recently they decided to
retire the word transitory they waved
the white flag they gave up inflation is
not transitory we've got over six months
now of five plus percent official
inflation on top of that we have two
straight months of over six percent
official inflation the unofficial
numbers are much worse at least double
and their double-digit inflation and the
people at the bottom of our society and
our economy are getting absolutely
destroyed financially because we have
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
so if we go ahead and we start to break
this down when you look at this next
chart you can see that there are all
sorts of things that are feeding into
this energy food all sorts of goods
services everything is up
it's all up driving both the headline
and core inflation headline or cpi
inflation at 6.8 percent core inflation
if you take out things like food and
energy still at 4.9
so if you use all the normal goods and
services you have 6.8 inflation but if
you could pull off a miracle and not use
food or energy or shelter you still
would be experiencing almost 5
inflation
this is a serious serious problem it's
not a joke it's not a drill inflation is
a threat to 45 of americans purchasing
power because they hold no investable
assets they are being destroyed because
we have undisciplined policy
if we go ahead and we look at the
individual assets charlie bolello had a
great breakdown gasoline is up 58
mic drop this is absurd are you kidding
me
it's not only because of monetary and
fiscal policy we also are shutting down
pipelines we're releasing strategic
reserves we have all sorts of [ __ ]
going on in the gasoline market but it's
58
increase year over year you tell me a
society that can sustain a society that
is using gasoline and other types of
energy
prices go up 58 year over year this is
absurd used cars are up 31 gas utilities
up 25 good luck it's winter time get
ready to pay your heating bill
meat fish eggs 12 new cars up 11. if you
want transportation i don't care if you
buy a new or used car you're paying
double digits more
overall cpi's at 6.8 electricity you
just want to have electricity we've had
electricity for a century
but now you got to pay 6.5 more than you
were paying last year if you want to eat
literally your human body wants food
i don't care if you eat at home if you
eat away if you get fast food or you go
to a five-star restaurant you're paying
at least
5.8 more and if you eat at home you pay
6.4
more
apparel transportation and shelter all
up big as well anyone who believes these
numbers
i got a lot of nonsense to sell you
these are the official numbers the
unofficial numbers are way worse if you
think shelter is only up 3.8 percent i
got a lot of things to sell you
i recently looked at miami real estate
like going on zillow rentals
and also real estate for sale
most of it is up 20 to 25
over the last year
that is not being counted in these
numbers
if we look on a country by country basis
how
bad is the united states maybe it's just
everyone has really high inflation
wrong
if we go ahead and we look at this we
can see
japan basically is flat
finland
has got 3.2 percent italy and the uk
around four
philippines 4.2 india 4.5 south africa 5
normally we would go and we would preach
and we would say look at these countries
this undisciplined monetary and fiscal
policy they have no clue what they're
doing they're hurting their citizens
they're attacking their citizens that's
so poorly managed
the united states got 6.8 percent
so does poland
and we're only better than mexico russia
brazil turkey argentina and venezuela my
friends that's a list you don't want to
be on
imagine that
if you ask siri or alexa to tell you
name the countries with the highest
inflation
and they hit you with a list that says
well the top
eight countries or venezuela argentina
turkey brazil russia mexico poland and
the united states
we failed we get an f minus for our
performance
and it's no longer transitory and it's
hurting the people who are most
vulnerable in our society
and so if we go ahead and we look and we
skip to this idea that charlie bolello
has where he says after adjusting for
inflation
maybe we should look at the treasury
yields well they're down
minus
5.4 percent
we have negative yielding debt in the
united states on a real return basis
every single pension fund in america
every single endowment in america every
single foundation and most wall street
institutions are holding assets that are
guaranteed to lose value it is a
guarantee that you will lose money if
you hold on to this asset
and so if you zoom out and say well
maybe it's not just the individual
assets that they hold maybe those
pension funds are actually doing okay
most pension funds have an actuarial
rate of return what is their target
their goal of seven to seven and a half
percent but as we know many of the
pension funds in america haven't been
achieving their goals they're under
performing and so if they've been
posting five five and a half six six and
a half percent annualized returns
they have lost money
the money that you have in your pension
plan
is literally losing value it's going
negative
rather than growing as they promised
and so inflation eats away
at everyone's assets
if you do not have investable assets
that are growing at more than seven
percent a year you're losing
on top of that if today in 2021 in
december you do not make seven percent
or more than you are getting paid in
december of 2020
you've lost you are making less money on
a purchasing power basis your employer
is paying you less
and so ultimately what we get is there
are real ramifications to this type of
inflation
there are real problems
people get hurt this isn't a game this
isn't just a number that gets posted
once a month
this is the real life economy
if the official numbers are 6.8 percent
again the off unofficial number is
somewhere between 12 to 15 percent
we can't continue like this i don't know
if it goes up sideways are down from
here but what i know is that if we go
back to what they were telling us last
year and earlier this year this was
never supposed to happen they were never
gonna let this happen it told us not to
worry
so maybe we should stop listening or
start thinking for ourselves we should
start actually being prepared for the
incompetency
and the bad results that show up
when you have monetary and fiscal policy
that the incentive for politicians and
central bankers is to continue to
manipulate interest rates
do quantitative easing and flood the
market with liquidity
because they have no other choice they
are backed into a corner and they are
going to continue to do this stuff if
they raise interest rates too high
they'll crash the stock market and
they'll bankrupt the united states of
america so the only thing that they have
to do
is to continue down this path
and so me
my brothers
and many people i know
we're not going to sit around and allow
them to simply attack us
we just opt out